guess. So here is an example of using combining POI with ABC. So we have A, B, and the C leg
goes into this autoblock, right? You can say this right here, price goes straight into
this autoblock here. So, and it also takes out liquidity or the high of the leg. So you
have A, B, and C. Now what you have here is a market structure shift here. And you also
have market structure shift here. And you also have a market structure shift here. Cool.
After that, you have your autoblock here, right? You see this fair body gap. So your
autoblock could be this right here, considering this high as well. And you shot it right here,
right? And you put your stop there just like that. And you target the low here, which is
a six risk to reward trade. So notice how we took this autoblock or supply zone into consideration.
The C leg goes into this level. We had a market structure shift, right? And we took our entry from
this extreme fair body gap plus OB, right? You could put your stop here as well. But, you know,
I usually like to put them here, but it's also safe to put it here. Okay, I'm not saying that
you should put it here. You should put it here as just like if you want, if you want to, right?
But for me, I do not care about losing a trade. My psychology is good. So even if I lose this,
price goes back here and reverses, I'm going to be fine because, you know, unlike some people,
if, you know, if they put their stop loss here and it gets stopped and it just reverses from this
area, you would be mad, right? So just keep it there. You don't want to mess around with the,
oh, never mind. So we got the 3.25, you could say, or six or we were screwed on. And this was a
perfect example on how you can use ABC with POI.